[Music]
okay tom brady i guess is pretending to
be a tick-tock influencer now he's got a
tick tock with jack no it's doing the
jack dance oh let's start with that yeah
go for it
what are you doing
nothing
no don't worry about it
he's coming back for one more season
right yeah why does he look like the una
bomber
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's got the he's got a unibomber face
man are we sure he didn't do it i don't
know after watching the first 30 minutes
that john wayne gacy [ __ ] and this is
kind of piggybacking on the conversation
i had last week we were thinking about
how
crazy it is that i think the fbi like
estimates they're like 80 active serial
killers still what yeah we should get
one of them on the pod
yeah that'd be a good idea so you're one
of the 80 yeah and you are an active
serial killer what's that like what's
that like trying to pick your brain a
little bit dude it's so [ __ ] man
that's pretty crazy there's a theory
that a lot of them operate in like
indigenous lands uh because it's like
tribal law i don't know because like
indigenous women go go missing all the
time at like a [ __ ] alarming rate
right super scary yeah sorry said the
kid cudi the [ __ ] yeah that's creepy as
[ __ ]
so scary like john wayne gacy he kind of
blended in with his community but like
the other scary one is that do the btk
killer this dude was scary because he
had like a family with kids he was a
park ranger super involved in his
community didn't necessarily tick the
boxes yeah visually definitely he does
yeah but you could you could you could
look like this in the 80s and 90s and
people thought you were normal yeah you
know
that's the other crazy [ __ ] whenever i
go to the midwest teenagers there versus
teenagers in la it's a hilarious
difference why i'll go i'll do some
shows there'll be a couple like you know
dudes that have the exes on their hands
and i'm like okay and they're eating
chicken nuggets so i know they're kids
they have like full mustaches
like [ __ ]
wallets there was this kid who came to
show in omaha this kid was 23 built like
a [ __ ] 80s linebacker huge and it was
funny because i asked him questions and
he had the most 23 year old personality
like oh man i just like beer but
everything else about him screamed 45.
[Laughter]
i like to drink beer do you guys have
any drugs i could buy okay dinklebob all
right tinglebob say
oh no no
[Applause]
dinklebob we knew it was you
officer dinklebob
i forget what what part of the single
bob was that just me moaning at him
right he's easily swayed yeah anyway
let's keep going tom brady tick tocks
oh shirt on there's trap already you
want me to step on it what you call an
icon living start a record label miss
fish just didn't dig
did we just watch a gray sweatpants tom
brady yeah we we really did
we just got dick and ball yeah man i
know all the [ __ ] boomer comments are
on there already dude what don't let my
husband know i've seen oh yes for sure
those balls weren't deflated
can we get a different kind of signature
ball what is this i'm a 38 year old
man
married happily with four kids yet
you're right hi tom holy [ __ ]
unbelievable man the kids are at soccer
practice
now he plays for the buccaneers it
should be called the [ __ ] heirs yeah
nice [ __ ] here yeah
nice my zero weight track jacket
looks pretty great that's what we're
trying to sell right here i gotta take a
new phone so let's make a movie you want
me to step on it
what you call the icons that's the worst
tip
how many jokes are you trying to
shoehorn into this just one man just one
also like when you stomp on the phone
it's supposed to be like the fit is
supposed to be insane afterwards yeah
here's my waterproof track jacket yeah
yeah
looks pretty cool i think i know your
fingers hovering over that play button
no i'm not i don't care
what other comments do we have bro tom
keep up the amazing work and dedication
he's not your friend man he doesn't
[ __ ] know you
these comments kill me man he does not
care about you tom's not cruising like
let me see what the people think of this
tech talk no way this dude 43.
all right next okay hi here you go
he's going to hit us going to turn into
a bunch of legos
i'll never trust you again
his team you know it's like you got to
get on tick tock tick tock's the new
platform trust me everyone's on it and
we're gonna pair you with a magician
zach king and he'll come up with
something cool and you guys will do it
together and tom's like that's fine i
have 50 million dollars yeah i'm down to
do whatever
you